and it's cradled in this mountain here
almost like a a Grail and in some ways
the poet tries to hold that same kind of
cup where everything meets okay let's
start again we won't have that kind of
bad luck and too often I huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you mentioned this concept the
ecological imagination so obviously this
is sort of the distillate for you here
some of your thinking here so say
something about it what is it exactly
well it's an imagination where the image
itself has many different realities
constellated within it it isn't an image
that you're trying to impose on the
world it's an image that's received
after you've remained quiet and you're
willing to pay attention to the miracle
of creation as it is now that miracle
may take the form of despair and
alienation as it has over the last 60
years but you pay attention to it you
know we live in a monocultural society
where you plant wheat in one field and
you spray down on either side so you get
one crop and and the soil which comes
from the same root as the word soul
suffers as a result you know in the
Eastern Palace of Washington State
they've lost twenty-five to fifty feet
of topsoil you know through intensive
mining almost mining agriculture and
here we are in the Botanic Gardens in
Prague where plants have been brought
from all over the world it's a in some
ways it's a it's a wish by humanity to
recreate the beauty and imagination of
the rainforest or of an ecology that
where things fit together exquisitely
and we have this inside us we have this
this patterning this understanding that
that the world fits together absolutely
exquisitely and we have a possibility of
fitting together too so the poet remain
silent looks out at the world which sees
all the images that comes in and tries
to say the one word that represents the
whole ecology of everything that is
received and hopefully will give birth
to that world in in the word in the line
but this suggests somehow that the word
is made flesh or in your metaphor the
flesh is made word yes
yes all the wood is made ecology the
Lord has made the ecology well so this
is an aesthetic of nature almost
Emersonian minute scope this is a far
cry from futurism or the glorification
of the technological that a lot of 20th
century poetics has been about yeah do
you see yourself as a part of a
conservative impulse in poetry or
reforming impulse how does that work no
I don't see it as being conservative it
may be looked at that way from from the
from the areas of art which say Andy
Warhol inhabited where the whole
emphasis was on the latest wave that was
breaking on the shore
I said yes fashion and the whole sea
that was behind each wave as it came
upon the shore was ignored and so I
think what there is now is a resting
back a swimming out as diving down into
that sea to re-establish our eldership I
think much of what's happening in the
20th century is a reestablishment of
eldership I mean here we are in Prague
Prague has been almost has been asleep
almost like Rip Van Winkle for the last
40 years anyway 40 years possibly longer
and it's awaking again it's awaking and
there's so much awaking in the world
today and I think poetry has always been
the art where you remind people of what
life is about and what is essential to
it and what as as Pericles said what is
what is sweet and what is terrible about
life that you have to know both of those
things
the poet ignores neither so hopefully
it's not the kind of conservatism while
you're trying to go back to summer
Zdenek roof so istic pass where everyone
can gather under one oak tree and
discuss the problems of the village
that's never going to never going to
happen but the port neither he does not
hide or she does not hide the beauty of
life
and does not hide the alienation you
know the century we have tremendous
emphasis on looking into the cracked
mirror of alienation and saying look at
where we are
I mean Eliot's the wasteland was all
about that but there's another side to
it too you can only do that for so long
otherwise you know you have no more
impetus to go on that there has to be
here let's go you know there has to be
some kind of healing that can only be so
much of this existential austerity well
he came up to a tree you said and he put
his finger on the tree and he says he
said life is absurd because I cannot
understand that tree I cannot become I
cannot get my soul into that tree well
there's n patriarchs have been talking
about this for 1500 years and you
weren't supposed to get your
consciousness into the tree you are
supposed to pay such tremendous
attention to the tree that it came to
find you
yes that nature is mute which is to me
one of the most amazing statements in a
20th century philosopher is made in
terms of defining alienation I think
that would have to be it would be very
successful with that philosophers over
there welded to materialism well so at
this conference there's been a lot of
talk about hope where and where did the
poet's come down are you singing a
funeral dirge for a world passing away
or is this the bright birth of the new
young prince well hopefully I mean
hopefully neither in some ways because
you simply have to speak life as it is
so at this time we're speaking
tremendous change we're speaking the
stakes are very high you can fail in
life an individual human being can fail
in life a species can fail in life I
mean in some ways we always live out our
destiny
no matter what we do it just depends
what level you want to live out that
destiny if you want to live out your
destiny on the level of frustration
because you can do that or do you want
to step further and deeper into it so
poetry says always says the stakes are
very high and it relies on on the fact
that life itself is magnificent
you speak about magnificence of the
magnificence of life not in a
pollyannish sense or in a sense in which
you're going to ignore all the
difficulties and terrible beauties of
life but in the sense that it's it's
magnificent because you can fail at it
and we as a species can fail so the hope
of the poet is that you can you can
speak to the magnificence of life such
that people will be reminded that life
is magnificent and you can fail you fail
at it and the stakes are very very high
the stakes for your life so that's
almost a bardic manifesto what do you
feel moved to speak some poetry will
move from talking about poetry to
speaking poetry yes well we spoke about
the tree earlier and having them having
the world come and find you and and I
remind of a very simple form that this
is very powerful form to me it's a it's
a a teaching story actually out of the
Northwest Indian tradition where the
story is there to tell a young boy or
girl what to do when they're lost in the
forest or it's all to answer the
question and when the young boy or girl
asks the question what do I do when I'm
last in the forest the elder tells his
story been rendered into marvelous
modern English by David Wagoner when as
the chair of poetry at the University of
Washington in the Northwest United
States and it's a very simple form
called lost and here it says take the
burden off your shoulders basically
historians say
so the young bar girl says to thee to
the elder what are you and I'm lost in
the forest and the elders say stand
still the trees ahead and bushes beside
you are not lost stand still the trees
ahead and brushes beside you are not
lost wherever you are is called here and
you must treat it as a powerful stranger
must ask permission to know it and be
known listen listen the forest breathes
it whispers I have made this place
around you if you leave it you may come
back again saying here saying here if
you leave it you may come back again
saying here no two trees are the same -
Raven no two branches are the same - ran
for a tree or a branch does is lost on
you then you're surely lost what a tree
or a branch does is lost on you then you
are
where you are
wonderful thank you well thank you to
David Wagoner and the Salish elders from
them well you give it life but you know
the Zen patriarchs used to say that if
you if you go out and confirm the ten
thousand things this is delusion
if the ten thousand things come and
confirm you this is enlightenment now I
wish one had been around to mention this
to Sartre you know the next is they
might have understood that the Germans
were at their border well we could have
avoided a painful moment in history for
sure well thank you for coming you're
talking to us we've been talking with
David White poet shaman philosopher
thanks very much thank you
wonderful be here in Prague with you
well nice to have a chance to talk to
you again you did that very well
[Music]
[Music]
great Terrance Terrance
can I get you to stay there just for a
sec we were with David they want us back
right here don't talk and just give me
10 seconds or 20 seconds okay don't talk
don't be on something easy assignment
did you see the have you had a chance to
appreciate all this you can steal of
Architects oh yeah tsubame saying I need
to sound just at the water
okay you're free to talk
are we free to move are you done with us
go ahead move okay good
that's it well that was we make it look
easy
yes true you have our whole of the Bob
you